welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange of the
multiverse of madness presents itself as
a big screen sequel to one division but
is it really the second half of that
title is a complete no-show where was
vision in all of this either the vision
in the alternate universe that we
visited who presumably was still alive
in that reality or even our old pal
white vision loose somewhere in 616. i
mean did white vision really spend
months letting a book turn wanda evil
while he rebuilt sam wilson's boat into
the egyptian duat ship while he lectured
tarwitt about theseus i mean that's a
spin-off but based on a number of visual
clues in this film and some more recent
clarification from the cast and crew i
can now explain to you the status of
vision in doctor strange the multiverse
of madness why he must be alive in 838
why he's not with wanda and where we
will see his forms next now vision did
come up twice in multiverse of madness
first during strange and wanda's chat in
the orchard this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous he was
right
and then later when wanda arrived to
camartage when she said i blew a hole
through the head of the man i love and
it meant nothing now one of vision
showed us vision's fate back in the 616
universe his corpse was taken by sword
and reanimated as white vision whose
memories were unlocked after hex visions
ship of theseus paradox and he blasted
off to some unknown fate presumably
nautical themed meanwhile hex vision
vanished as wanda dropped her hex from
westview leaving us with this beautiful
exchange i have been a voice with nobody
a body but not human and now
a memory
made real
who knows what i might be next
we have said goodbye before
so it stands to reason
again
so what new form does vision take in
multiverse of madness 6161 to dreamwalks
into two to three alternate universe
west views the first act shows her
accidentally dreaming with her sons as
they bake brownies the second act shows
her using the dark hole to commentage to
dreamwalk into a west view where the
boys are watching oswald the lucky
rabbit and sing about ice cream one of
the creepier scenes in the movie but
that dreamwalk link fades when sarah
destroys the dark hole so then later on
in the movie wanda uses the darkhold
temple to dreamwalk into 838 wanda the
one she uses to slaughter the illuminati
and the one who ultimately forgives her
at the end of the film all three of
these west views are not false illusory
hexes like we saw in one division these
are real tangible homes in these
realities when possessed a38 wanda flies
away from her house toward the moon
she's not crossing through any hex
barrier she's flying directly from 838
new jersey to 838 manhattan these are
realities where wanda did not need to
use a hex to create her perfect suburban
life she was able to build it for real
because these are realities where vision
survived infinity war and we know for
certain that in 838 vision a existed and
b survived we know he survived because
that shot of 838 thanos infinity
gauntlet on titan proves thanos did not
yet acquire the mind stone and that it
must still be in vision's forehead and
we know vision exists in this universe
because the 838 baxter foundation has
ultron sentries and ultron only
replicated himself into centuries late
in that movie after the ai tony made for
his iron legion drones was corrupted
after ultron made a new android body of
this design and after he began building
a new synthazoid that later became
vision the only way multiple ultron
centuries would logically exist would be
if the 838 avengers were able to
reprogram them during the final battle
of sokovia at which point vision was
already spawned but it had to get to
that point and we know it did because in
838 wanda's subconscious she's buried
under sokovian rubble therefore for her
that age of ultron origin story was the
same and so too was it for vision
therefore 838 vision is a vision who
never died in infinity war allowing him
and wanda to live on in their intended
path of building a house on that plot of
land in west view that vision had
already purchased for her and then
having two sons now how did they
conceive those sons without the hex well
kids i really should be careful here
when i talk about personhood via mcu
witchcraft in case i ever get quoted in
any supreme court opinions but one of my
favorite lines in multiverse of madness
was when strange tells wanda your
children weren't real you created them
using magic and wanda replies that's
what every mother does wanda did not
need the hex to actually conceive these
kids she only needed vision and the hex
provided the surrounding context to that
conception now it's not that wanda
cannot reproduce asexually i mean she
can manifest pretty much anything it
seems but these particular kids billy
and tommy are as much products of wanda
as they are a vision we clearly see
vision of wanda fooling around under the
sheets in episode two and when asked
about the mechanics of this paul bettany
confirmed that vision can change his
density and that quote he's purple and
age of ultron confirmed that vision was
made partially with human tissue from dr
helen cho so it's not all
metal blood is pumping and how now if
some of your favorite heroes were
non-fictional they'd probably be working
to fight the climate crisis instead of
alien invaders or demons or alternate
versions of themselves well thanks to
ren for sponsoring this video ren is a
simple and effective way to make a
difference in the climate crisis it is a
website where you can calculate your
carbon footprint then offset it by
funding carbon reduction projects like
tree planting mineral weathering and
rainforest protection by answering just
a few questions about your lifestyle you
can find out your carbon footprint and
how to reduce it you can't reduce their
carbon footprint to zero but you can
offset what you have left after reducing
you receive updates from the projects
you support with photos and details on
every tree planted and every ton of
carbon offset it was pretty eye opening
to take their carbon footprint test and
realize that i'm doing worse than the
average american on some things i'm
super excited about their mineral
weathering project in scotland it's a
process where they sequester carbon in
the ground and it's really one of the
first of its kind folks it's going to
take a lot to mitigate this climate
crisis and you can start helping today
by learning more on ren.co offset your
carbon footprint on wren the first 100
people who sign up using the link in the
description will have 10 extra trees
planted in their name that's pretty
great in these other realities vision
survived wanda never cast a westview hex
they built their home as intended and
banged and somewhere between visions
phase shifting part flesh purple parts
and wanda's womb magic gave them billy
and tommy so where is vision now well
elizabeth olsen actually shed some light
on this in an interview with collider
steven weintraub did anyone ever explain
to you why you're not actually also
searching for vision in one of the other
multiverses
no i've i
there are
um there's like a whole list of things
that um like my brother
my parents
um i think
uh
the
the main reason when we would talk about
um
you know if there is this multiverse and
in this in in the version of the of the
of the universe this woman wasn't with
vision
um
she
we that we liked having that be a
mystery but for some reason he's not in
her in her world and we thought you know
i always thought of her as kind of more
of a domestic wanda they got a divorce
they're separated she's not wearing a
wedding band for a reason you know like
those kinds of things
um
we liked the idea of her being on her
own but um
the idea really is that
the most important thing once you become
a mother in the world are your children
and that's why yes olsen points out that
838 wanda wears no wedding band and in a
38 she envisioned were divorced or
separated she's a single mother now that
doesn't mean vision is dead or not in
the picture like i imagine the guy would
be a wonderful co-parent in a joint
custody agreement taking those boys out
for pizza balls every other weekend or
you know maybe he just leaves them in a
single bedroom apartment as he and pizza
papa get drunk on fireball we know that
cinnamon kick gets vision tipsy
either way vision is alive in 838 taking
some new form as he promised wanda he
would in the one division finale but
apparently a form that like many
husbands prefers [ __ ] metaphors to
couples therapy and as i explained in
another video a381a is now left behind
as the culprit for the murders of the
838 illuminati and likely will face the
consequences from the remaining marvel
leaders the rest of the x-men the rest
of the avengers the fantastic
three and that witch trial could be what
brings divorced vision back to wanda's
side so meanwhile back in 616 white
vision are we really that surprised he
never checked in on wanda as the
darkhold corrupted her in that cabin in
one of the vision episode 9 the
synthazoid tried to give wand to the
black vault treatment
and i was told people powerful
now yes hex vision unlocked his memories
but white vision seemed more in a place
of self-discovery than love for wanda
and as a wmd rebuilt by sword white
vision remains an interesting candidate
for armor wars or maybe a mentor to a
young avengers lineup but i like the
idea that as an easily malleable
synthazoid you make a pretty fun target
for agatha harkness and neck of the
house of harkness whoo think about it
now that 616 wanda seems to be gone and
the darkhold is destroyed agatha might
be liberated from that hex that wanda
left her under you know agatha is gonna
need a new ralph boytoy to clean her
gutters uh i didn't intend that to be an
innuendo but i am now wondering what
color white visions parts are i mean
you'd think white but you know
you never really know the best way to
support this channel is to check out our
great merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com including our new
latest obsession shirt inspired by
multiverse of madness shattered madness
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos following the rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you